buttons there everywhere watching
waiting but can we trust them one day on
my weekly walk to the pet store to look
at the turtles
I wondered do crosswalk buttons really
work or are these buttons merely I like
to believe that they're real because I
have hope in humanity that they're not
lying to me yeah I think they're real
because they make noise no absolutely
not I mean the few times that I pressed
them that they actually quote-unquote
work I'm guessing it's just coincidence
otherwise what am i what am i pressing
them for they have to work a New York
City Department of Transportation
spokeswoman told ABC News that only
about 9% of crosswalk buttons in New
York actually work you're about as
likely to find a working crosswalk as
you are to find meat in a vegetarian
hotdog
wait what I feel betrayed I feel
betrayed
I still have hope that it is real and I
won't believe that until I die it's the
same in other cities according to the
Dallas Morning News nearly all of
downtown Dallas is 200 traffic signals
are on a time system this got my little
noodle churning what else is a lie turns
out their other buttons pulling the wool
over our eyes it's reported that some
New York City subway doors may also have
placebo buttons because they and I quote
open and close automatically you might
as well just walk some office
thermostats may also be placebos which
render no effect on how cold or hot your
offices
but instead just give you and your
co-workers something to fight about and
elevator closed or buttons according to
the head of the National elevator
industry closed door buttons were
eliminated when the a DEA Act was passed
in 1990 which gives rights to Americans
with disabilities
ok so a lot of them are placebos but
wait here's a thought could these
placebos actually be good for us
according to some experts yeah pushing a
button and receiving a response whether
it's actually caused by you or not
reinforces a new
of control I think many of us would
argue that the feeling of being in
control is well pretty dang good dr.
Ellen Langer a professor of psychology
at Harvard University also claims the
act of pushing crosswalk buttons may
make pedestrians more aware of changing
traffic making them less likely to put
themselves in danger she told the New
York Times perceived control is very
important it diminishes stress and
promotes well-being the world is full of
the unknown like will this gas station
sandwich give me food poisoning will the
turtles actually let me pet them this
time sometimes it's nice to know exactly
what's going to happen even if it is
manufactured
[Music]
you
[Music]